all right it's easy to look at sky high
summer fairs and assume that the days of
cheap flights are over but that is not
the case we check in with our friends at
scott's cheap flights for how to save
money when booking travel for later this
summer and for the fall or winter
nearly 70 percent of people planning
summer vacations say they anticipate
making changes to their itineraries
because of inflation this according to a
new survey by bankrate even more are
actively searching for ways to save on
travel today sky high prices more likely
than not a temporary reaction to an
extreme surge in demand and that's why
there's never been a better time to be
flexible with your plans scott kais says
if you can delay your travel plans to
the end of summer or the beginning of
fall the so-called shoulder season you
can save an average of 120 dollars per
flight those with international plans
who push their plans into fall stand to
save even more just in the past week or
two alone we've seen cheap flights from
las vegas to maui for 278 bucks round
trip flights from las vegas out to the
bahamas for 294 dollars round trip or
down to columbia for 278 round trip
those types of deals pop up if you book
a few months in advance like now if you
wait until the last minute chances are
those cheap flights will be gone and all
that's left will be the expensive ones
and if you're hoping to get a cheap
flight for this winter don't wait book
now this summer is when those cheap
flights during the fall and winter are
popping up